breakthrough on the h6 square looking
forward to that the direct window
apparently starts with this rook
sacrifice but it's not easy i don't
really see the follow-up um after white
gives up a rook i think the idea is to
now bring your rook forward and uh now
you have three pieces lined up against
this near-pawn that's only defended by a
knight but i don't think this is human i
don't think anishikari is going to find
this i definitely wouldn't find it
myself during a game so this is the
winning sacrifice but
is there something else maybe the white
knight needs to relocate maybe the white
knight can step back or into the
position
so many options anishigiri he knows if
he wants he can gain a bit of time by
giving a queen check but we've seen this
position before still no way
no means closer to the black king
okay this is the current position
what do you think here
anchor simon what is he going to play
okay he does bring his rook up to this
square this feels so logical but now
prague actually indirectly has lot